ce match sent un peu soulagé
un grand pas vers un peu plus de vérité
l'arrivée des secours c'est sûr puis en
plus ce avocats nous ont beau marteler
sa version pendant des mois
je l'avais déjà dit ça aurait pu pousser
certaines personnes ne suffit de manger
des cinémas battre j'ai bien fait ma
demande et la confrontation
on l'a eu il a craqué aujourd'hui les
retombées sur sept a vu mon temps en
temps vers la bri
et encore des choses à dire mais passion
l'a souhaité on l'a tellement on la
voulait tellement pouvoir jeudi raconter
des choses
un bureau d'un juge qu'à regarder les
personnes qu'on accuse droit dans les
yeux en racontant sa version c'est pas
pareil en racontant ses mensonges c'est
pas pareil et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui si grégory à moi on
travaille essentiellement sur les
éléments techniques qui ne tenait pas
que monsieur d'aval ne pouvait même pas
réfuté sur des éléments une
contre-vérité la vie donc évidente
on voit bien situe à l'affect avait un
rôle très important pour pour délier
cette histoire et c'est le rôle le rô le
central ont joué mes parents donc dans
cette confrontation